I come from a small island called Camiguin
in southern Philippines,
land of seven volcanoes
and the famous sweet lanzones fruits.
As a kid, I would go to the forest
with my father, a healer.
He would take me by the hand and whisper,
"Tabi apo!"
"Permit me," to respect spirit,
the majesty of giant trees.
Often he would look me
straight in the eye and say,
"Spirits, forests, lanzones.
They nurture us.
You nurture them back.
You work with the people who know how."
I share this pain.
Now seeing our world's
tropical rainforests cut down,
hearing the cry of the world’s wildlife,
losing their habitats,
listening to reports
of forest guardians under threat.
In 2020, over 200 Indigenous
and environmental defenders were lost.
Illegal loggers, illegal logging
is linked to almost a third
of these murders.
With their deaths
and the death of forests,
something is also lost in us.
Our abilities to survive
the climate crisis.
Pressure is building.
At COP26 last year,
governments, NGOs, corporations
all say yes to protecting forests
and land rights
and call on Indigenous peoples,
guardians of standing forests, for help.
Finally, we all agree.
We work with the people who know how,
in my father's words.
Over 20 years ago in my own hometown
in southern Philippines,
Indigenous peoples, activists,
all put their own lives
on the line as fighters.
They protect their forests
against illegal loggers,
companies and miners
who want to take their land.
My own fiancée,
a brave Indigenous young man,
was killed in that fight.
For years, I thought I was a coward.
Unlike my fiancée,
I chose the pen, not the gun.
I chose to set up
a legal defense organization,
stood with brave Indigenous
women and men as barefoot lawyers.
I struggled between hope and fear
when they asked,
"Can we really trust the laws?"
I barely had time to ponder.
You see, when Indigenous peoples,
activists protested,
they were tagged as communists.
So we set up quick reaction teams
to respond 24/7 to their legal needs.
And this work led to the passage
of an ancestral domain law
in the Philippines
that set up an Indigenous
People's Commission
and recognized 4 million hectares
of ancestral land claims.
This --
(Applause)
was shared through Indonesia's legal aid
and legal rights defenders
who work and strengthen the Indonesia’s
Alliance of Indigenous Peoples,
and they won their forest
land rights case in court.
Today 476-million-strong
Indigenous peoples
look after 80 percent
of our world’s biodiversity.
So I joined the Tenure Facility
five years ago.
Based in Stockholm,
we finance
mapping and legal defense
of collective land rights,
so communities globally
can protect themselves,
protect forests and protect nature.
This is how we do it.
We work with credible communities
who are forest guardians
positioned to protect
large tracts of tropical rainforest
in the Amazon and Central America,
Congo Basin and tropical Asia.
And in these countries,
laws and policies already exist
to recognize rights,
but they're not implemented.
Because communities
and their partners in government
lack support, funding and capacity
to turn this promise to reality.
For example,
in Panama, we assisted the Federation
of Indigenous Peoples COONAPIP
and their ally in government,
and now they've recognized 200,000
hectares of their Indigenous lands,
and today they protect a million hectares
of Indigenous people’s lands and forests,
and they monitor it.
In Liberia, we worked
with 24 customary communities
and their allies in government
and women land rights groups.
And they now recognize and protect
600,000 hectares of their
customary land and forests.
In Indonesia, we assisted
the Alliance of Indigenous Peoples,
and farmers and women,
and they together recognized
and registered 1.2 million hectares
of their ancestral
land claims and forests.
And together they buffer
large tracts of forest in Indonesia.
Protecting rights
to manage lands and forests
is not only protecting biodiversity,
it is also a climate change solution.
And it is a very powerful leverage
to our world's climate mitigation work.
And it is supporting the visions
of intergenerational stewardship
of Indigenous peoples.
We have shown it's possible.
Today, since 2017,
Indigenous peoples, our partners,
have advanced recognition
of their land rights and forests
to up to 14 million hectares,
benefitting seven million people
in 12 countries.
And with TED’s Audacious support,
we can leverage this momentum
and expand, secure and protect
up to 50 million hectares
of land and forests.
And reach --
(Applause)
reach 50 million forest guardians
in the next five years.
What we've learned is that when
in the midst of environmental destruction,
conflict and criminalization,
land tenure serves as a bridge.
It is an important link
that generates this possibility
of opening minds and hearts
for unusual parties, Indigenous peoples,
governments, private sector,
to come together to find a common solution
for a sustainable planet.
Already with secure tenure,
we see
conflicts resolved, less deforestation.
And most importantly, women.
Women have increased support
for their role as forest guardians,
as holders of traditional knowledge
and as decision makers for land use,
keepers of traditional knowledge.
And our youth,
Indigenous youth are coming home.
(Applause)
My journey with Indigenous peoples
has taught me deep humility and respect.
Knowing the dangers of protecting forests
they persist, they put their own families,
their culture, their own lives on the line
in order to secure our world's chance,
your chance,
my chance,
for a livable future.
No one should have to die
protecting forests.
We all have a choice, all of us,
to stand as allies,
to protect the protectors of our future,
to restore balance,
to survive the climate crisis.
Let us work with the people who know how.
Thank you.
(Applause)